Burton said to get its youngest prime
minister in modern history and the first
of Asian Heritage Rishi sunako succeeded
Liz trusses later in the coming hours so
not lost to trust over the summer in a
race to become the conservative party
leader however following her resignation
last week sunak was the only candidate
to get past the threshold of a hundred
votes in a ballot of conservative MPS
while Andrew Simmons is in London and is
joining us now Andrew these transfers of
Power are very oftenly uh very carefully
choreographed just talk us through
what's going to happen
well this is the third prime minister in
a matter of 50 days so the British
public is getting quite used to this
procedure it all starts in Downing
Street 10 Downing Street uh with Liz
truss uh the outgoing prime minister the
shortest serving prime minister in
British political history she will
assemble the cabinet for the last
farewell it will be brief she will say
goodbye to the staff also and then
appear it's expected she'll appear here
in Darling Street at the lectern to make
a a speech that'll be probably quite
brief she will then go to Buckingham
Palace where King Charles III is
expecting an audience with her and she
will formally resign from the government
she's already resigned as prime minister
with a notice that she would stay in
place until her replacement was found
that will be a fairly brief affair a
following protocol she will then leave
then Rishi sunak the man who she'd
beaten in the election challenge for
leadership over the summer with the
membership of the conservative party but
he was the choice of the Parliamentary
party and now it's all coming to
fruition for him he will be going to
meet King Charles and receive an
invitation to form a government which
he'll certainly be doing in a fairly
rapid way he will even he'll come here
to Downing Street in something like well
this is going to be about
two to three hours probably never three
and he will then address the nation
we've not heard a lot from him this has
been the most extraordinary uh
leadership election uh not one vote has
been cast uh there's he was only the
only Contender who got through the
threshold of 100 nominations
the fact that you're you're raising the
fact that that uh he we haven't actually
heard a lot from him that is something
that is resonating with a lot of people
isn't it because there's a lot of
speculation about how he's going to be
handling the situation that the country
is finding itself in at the moment not
least with the fact that the economy is
struggling people are finding it very
difficult to to pay for their groceries
a lot of people can't find jobs he's
going to be looked at to see what he's
going to do about those problems
foreign
pressure compounded by the Fiasco of
government this past two months he has
from the very get-go in trying to get
the prime minister's job put the economy
to the force so that's in his favor he's
also more or less predicted that trusts
would have a catastrophe with the
economy because she was using what he
termed during a TV debate uh fantasy
economics in fact fairy tale economics
as well he he was basically saying that
there had to be a really hard look at
cutbacks in many areas not just not just
that story of of trying to have
um tax cuts so what is the background
well he is technically right now he has
to form the government and then actually
get the midterm fiscal report out that's
due on the 31st that's next Monday
that's very tight they've already given
a report most of the information and the
actual acts of that Jeremy Hunt the
acting Finance Minister well not acting
actually formal finance minister right
now but but certainly he took over from
from Liz trust more or less in terms of
saving the economy from being monstered
by the markets which is absolutely big
crisis so that's the big issue he's got
the office of budget responsibility is
going through uh all of his the
information in that he may have to try
to extend that period by about three or
four days ahead of the bank of England
meeting and possibly putting up interest
rates again so there's a lot of things
to do he is aware of the crisis the
office for National statistics has given
a grim picture of the cost of living
saying that between June and September
it became much much more of a problem
particularly for ethnic minorities and
particularly for disabled people uh red
light going there green light going on
at Downing Street and a new prime
minister who warns quite simply that the
unity of the party is key he said unite
or die it's a grim Mantra but it's one
he's sticking to Andrew thank you very
much indeed Andrew Simmons talking to us
from London